revient à 19h en télé dès 5h demain
matin en radio
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir il sera longuement question de
théâtre ce soir dans le culture
premières mais aussi de cinéma théâtre
avec le collège albert lougnon des
élèves de troisième sont sur scène
demain l'espace saint paul pour les
retrancher une pièce de leur cru sur la
der des ders théâtre encore itinérant
celui là est plus engagé avec le tertre
bazar de stéphanie de force et marne
sont tannés conscientiser les mafate et
sur les enjeux environnementaux et la
transition énergétique
le titre de la pièce asa fade théâtre
avec notre chroniqueuse galma thouaré
avec j'aime beaucoup ce que vous faites
un spectacle de cirque intitulé vu
signer à présent avec le réunionnais
réalisateur passionné du 7e art yoann
jean-charles son premier long métrage
nuit de grève tourné à paris et toujours
la fiche chez nous une des grèves ou les
tribulations d'un corps et âme dans la
capitale
réalisation ce soir de pascal langlois
émission à suivre et à réécouter sur le
site de la première culture première
jean-paul mais la ddt
18h16 bon sorgen parole tout d'abord à
vous pour des idées de sorties
exactement alors cette semaine j'ai eu
un coup de coeur pour deux spectacles
totalement différent le premier comme
vous le disiez sais j'aime beaucoup ce
que vous faites c'est une comédie de
carole greep mise en scène à saint-andré
est mon second coup de coeur s'est vu un
spectacle aussi muet que le premier est
bavard alors vu c'est un personnage sur
scène c'est un spectacle qui mélange
théâtre d'objets et cirque miniature et
toute la pièce montre la manière
totalement décalée de ses personnages
d'utiliser divers objets de la vie
courante comme un mètre ruban en grille
pain ou encore un coupe ongles alors que
j'aime beaucoup ce que vous faites on
n'est pas du tout dans le même registre
j'imagine alors absolument pas déjà
faisait oublier une petite partie avait
commencé par parler de vues si vous
voulez bien heureux c'est pas grave vu
c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui se
prépare du thé à priori n'y a rien
d'inquiétant
il a même l'air plutôt sympathique notre
bonhomme mais très vite on comprend
qu'il est complètement d'argent en fait
c'est un petit bonhomme hyper ordonné
hyper méticuleux avec plein d'autres
sessions par exemple si fait tomber une
grosse boîte d'allumettes
il faut qu'ils rentrent chaque allumette
l'une après l'autre le sucre chez lui
ait coupé en à choir les miettes ont
inspiré à la paille et c'est son côté
mines
sus à l'extrême et sa manière
inhabituelle d'utiliser des objets qui
font tout le sel du spectacle c'est très
drôle surprenant est idéal pour une
sortie avec les enfants lors donc avec
j'aime beaucoup ce que vous faites on
n'est pas du tout dans le même registre
j'imagine absolument pas ce coup ci
c'est une pièce sur l'amitié le mensonge
et l'hypocrisie
le point de départ c'est un couple
pierre et marie en fait de jeu dix
couples mais en vérité ce sont deux
grosses langue de vipère ils partent en
voiture passer le week-end chez leurs
meilleurs amis
sauf qu'en conduisant ils ont mal
raccroché leur portable du coup leurs
hôtes entendent tout le mal que ces
serpents disent et pensent d'eux nous
spectateurs ne voyons les deux
situations en même temps sur scène c'est
à dire celle du couple au portable
allumé et celle des autres qui attendent
de pied ferme leur arrivée en contre on
se passe les retrouvailles comme on
imagine ses règlements de comptes à ok
corral avec coup de sang et coups de
boutoir bon je vous préviens ce n'est
pas aussi fin que certaines comédie de
sacha guitry
c'est un théâtre de boulevard où les
défauts des personnages sont exagérés
mais ça reste un spectacle correct pour
une soirée détente autour comme le
dirait gilles deleuze d'un texte
violemment critique
j'aime beaucoup ce que vous faites
benjamin waro vendredi 8 et 15 juin au
théâtre conflore à saint-andré vue
etienne manceaux vendredi 8 et samedi 9
au séchoir à saint leu
culture première la grande guerre
revisité par des élèves de troisième
ils ont écrit la pièce il l'a jouée l'an
mise en scène aidés de leurs professeurs
d'histoire de france et de la
documentaliste et d'une dernière plus
axé sur le théâtre et au final cela
donne les retrancher une histoire de
poilus du visuel revisité donc par ces
jeunes du collège albert lougnon du
guillaume saint paul une pièce écrite
dans le cadre du centenaire de la guerre
14 18
dans ce studio jade fléchon et ilana le
guen en troisième bonsoir alors
mesdemoiselles j'ai le désir
mesdemoiselles puisque ou sur les mecs
dans cette histoire il n'ya pas
d'acteurs ou sans les garçons il ya déjà
une minorité de garçons par rapport aux
filles et ce qui fait qu'il ya beaucoup
plus d'actrice féminine que masculine
manque du coup les les chiffons si dd
c'est embêtant quand on est femme de se
faire un ça nous permet de nous mettre
dans la peau du personnage nous glisser
dedans qu'on se maquille on devient des
poilus des soldats c'est ce qui est
intéressant de le très bon alors des
doigts jusqu'à un peu curieux j'ai lu
vos textes
ils sont vachement bien écrit l'un vous
avez vraiment écrire vos wii entièrement
les monologues ont été écrits de manière
individuelle chacun par un travail noté
et les lettres qui coupe à chaque fois
des séries monologue ont été écrits par
groupes de cinq ou six élèves profonde
quam un peu aidés non non nous savions
tous forces à celles d'anna qui pensent
que la radio on vous voit pas donc je
donne le prénom
oui non nous suivions toujours un
cheminement bien précis avec des
consignes quand même bien précises nous
devions vraiment mettre en avant les
émotions des soldats nous glisse hors
impôt de soldats et ce travail de
rédaction nous a bien pris plusieurs
mois et beaucoup d'efforts mais il fait
très intéressant vous avez commencé
quand quant à ce que l'idée est venue ce
sont nos professeurs d'histoire de
documentation de français qui
travaillent beaucoup ensemble
l'année dernière nous avions déjà
travaillé sur un projet
qu'ils s'appellent la flamme de
l'égalité on travaille sur l'esclavagé à
la réunion et c'est notre professeur
d'histoire qui a eu l'idée de ce projet
en tout début d'année donc 2017
non oui vous jouissez sa début d'année
début d'année scolaire 2017 et nous
avons ensuite fait le choix d'une
représentation théâtrale
alors ça s'est passé comment gérer les
répétitions tout ça parce que vous avez
écrit la pièce
la mise en scène c'est vous c'est bien
césar est d'accord de la musique à une
musique ou pas encore en plus et dans
quelques heures à l'intérieur d'un
bunker c'est vrai j'ai l'élu en plus
donc à la musique qui sait qu'il a
écrite
si nous on a également l'air inspiré de
plusieurs champs de guerre et les
paroles écrites il ya que quatre ou cinq
verres répété plusieurs fois alors vous
êtes plonger dans l'histoire de france
il a bien fallu niveau 6 est passé par
votre programme cette année là la guerre
14-18 cesse ici
oui d'accord ok et donc vous avez
découvert des choses que vous ne saviez
pas sur cette guerre qu'on ne trouve pas
dans les livres ou alors bon toutou vous
êtes est connu il a n'a alors pour
approfondir nos connaissances de la
première guerre mondiale plus
profondément que ce que nous apportait
le programme d'histoire nous avons eu la
chance d'assister à une conférence de
deux historiens reconnus hardman reach
et nicolas offenstadt c'était une
conférence qui était à la base réservée
aux élèves de lycées ou étudiant en
histoire quand même vous situer à la
hauteur
oui bon oui je pense et alors ça qu'est
ce que va donner cette conférence que
l'abs a ouvert d'esprit allez vous à
vous permet de connaître des choses que
vous ne connaissez pas oui ça nous a
permis vraiment de voir de façon plus
approfondie de mieux comprendre le
contexte tout l'aspect historique a été
un peu plus clair pour ces durant la
première guerre mondiale mangeas ben oui
c'est un travail qui a été assez dur et
surtout retranscrire si vous voulez
l'horreur de façon littéraire de façon
politique avec énormément de métaphore
c'est quelque chose d'assez ya un gros
contraste si vous voulez entre les faits
qui se sont passés et la manière dont on
a de le présenter de le jouer enfin nous
en train de me dire que ce qu'on perçoit
nous à l'extérieur ça a l'air d'être on
sait que c'est à ça a été dur mais sans
plus mais quand on est plongé dedans on
on se rend compte de l'horreur est-ce
que ça ça vous a bouleversé pas
tellement parce qu'on va dire que c'est
des choses du moins de ma part que
j'entends depuis petit j'avais déjà
entendu si vous voulez donc on a grandi
en sachant l'histoire de france avec
vous voyez sur les jeux vidéo et thomas
grand temps que sa venue d'aurillac
alors justement je votre pièce dure
combien de temps environ 45 minutes
voire une heure d'accord et il ya
combien de dauphin de comédien il ya des
filles me semble et un garçon oui non il
ya plus dur car ce il y en a deux ou
trois ou deux ou trois alors vous allez
nous lire donc jade le même petit
passage donc de ce que vous avez écrit
élèves de troisième puisque vous m'avez
dit que c'est vous et non pas les
professeurs pour qu'on se rende compte
donc delà du côté lire de la littérature
vous avez écrite parce que vraiment je
suis très impressionné par ce que vous
avez écrit franchement annoncé je songe
à elle une nouvelle fois la faucheuse
l'une est gagnante de ce massacre ne
vous méprenez pas et ne vous croyez pas
vainqueur si elle n'est pas venu vous
chercher quand vous étiez dans la plaine
de la mort car quand la nuit tombera est
là siègera vos pensées se jouera de vous
je n'ai jamais été un héros et encore
moins survivants je suis comme ont été
mes frères un des pions de son échiquier
et je sais je sais que quand la nuit
embrasse la campagne elle vient danser
sur vos tombes et préparer la mienne
alors les répétitions et été facile ou
difficile de dire quand vous été
supervisés ou pas oui superviseurs qui
vous superviser tous les professeurs
dont professeur d'histoire professeur de
français et professeur de documentation
mais surtout donc madame aux anneaux
professeur de mathématiques dans notre
collège mais qui fait énormément de
théâtre en dehors donc donc on va dire
c'était aller un peu la metteur en scène
donc à vous donner des conseils est-ce
que vous pensez que vous étiez un peu
doué pour ça ou alors il a fallu tout
apprendre
ja c'est le nord il ya certains élèves
qui étaient plus à l'aise que d'autres
voulaient certainement mes enfants tous
d'accord ça a vraiment été un travail
qui s'est déroulée au cours de l'année
on a appris à s'approprier à
s'approprier nos textes excusez moi à
les mettre en scène
c'est ça qui est intéressant dans la
mise en scène c'est vraiment là qu'on
voit nos textes prendre vie donc on peut
les contextualiser qu'on peut faire
ressortir nos émotions s'approprier
knotek nous glisser dans la peau seule
la super travail de mémoire dont jeunes
oui c'est vrai que je pense que pour la
plupart des personnes le plus dur ça a
été de mémoriser les textes pour
certains ils sont beaucoup plus longs
que d'autres qui dieu ça peut durer
quand même 4 4 minutes 30 d'un monologue
c'était assez long et vouer et en même
temps se souvenir de ces paroles c'était
assez compliqué au début vous rendez
compte de la somme de travail que fait
qu'un comédien ou un acteur pour pouvoir
arriver à faire ce qu'il fait oui tous
les dessous d'une représentation tel que
celle ci c'est assez imprécis pourtant
donné que 45 minutes sur scène parce
qu'il ya des pièces de théâtre où les
gens sont une heure deux heures et
parfois des monologues qui dure il ya
des monologues dans le théâtre antique
qui dure une heure à se maquiller tout
seul sur scène elle répète son texte un
jeu jan charouz avait donc de futurs
acteurs non pour vous leur dites et
réalisateur des gens il faudra les
casses ou mieux poser comme question
donc tous que j'ai oublié mais c'est pas
grave on va demander donc à la jeune
fille de nous lire donc alors oui si je
retrouve ma question est ce que ça vous
est arrivé quand vous quand vous était
vraiment pris par le jeu d'être ému
voire même bouleversé retourner ilana
oui parce que c'est c'est quand même des
choses qui sont assez horrible qu'on
raconte doit vraiment faire transcrire
des émotions
c'est pour ça que par nos textes sont
écrits de façon poétique ça crée un réel
paradoxe et ça rend les choses encore
plus horrible
personnellement je trouve que ça m'a
particulièrement ému le jeu de jade m'a
particulièrement ému parce que c'est une
des sacs qui se débrouille le mieux
selon moi et franchement ça m'a déjà
arrivé d'être ému au point de presque
pleuré et les garçons là bas ils
réagissent comme en asie sont pas d'art
peur
c'est du souk sort de fonds va dire un
petit peu plus détaché que nous au
niveau de l'écriture mais il participe
quand même
ils ont une bonne relation dans la
représentation des corps bon alors vous
avez le trac là avant de de vannes au
départ on est quand même à quelques
heures c'est demain plus d'impatience
que de choses pour ma part c'est un an
de travail acharné
alors oui pour 45 minutes de scènes mais
45 minutes de scènes intenses et
personnellement je ressors très fier
parce que je sais que j'ai donné ma
personne que je me suis impliqué comme
le comme nous tous d'ailleurs est il
réellement je suis très fier donc plus
impatiente que trois choses les parents
sont contents de vous les parents ont
hâte de voir c'est vrai que quand leur
lit nos textes par exemple qui sont
assez impressionné de savoir qu'à notre
âge on peut écrire ce genre de choses et
il ya beaucoup d'impatience de la part
de tous les gens qui vont venir nous
voir demain le village ont été faits
quand on en a fait on a fait plusieurs
répétitions de filage et c'est déjà fait
donc on sait à peu près à quoi
s'attendre mais même si on ne sait pas
encore là le ressenti d'être face à plus
d'une centaine de personnes comme une
personne qui peuvent entrer dans la
salle de l'espace 200-300 dans non ce
qu'on sente 163 assez intimiste et nous
jouons à guichet fermé que vous posez
une question quel est le niveau de la
classe 19,8 18,8 en moyenne dans
viennent de lacoste
là-dessus je saurais pas dire quelle est
la moyenne de la classe l'épreuve du
relais a demandé lors ils vont vous dire
bon c'est quoi 15
c'est pas mal quand même 14 auriel
égalité prof doit être contente
d'entendre sans dynamisme une bonne
entente
c'est ça qui a été aussi intéressant
c'est de travailler qu'avec des
personnes impliquées et avec une bonne
entente d'accord donc on va terminer
avec vous il en a vous allez donc nous
dira un extrait de quelque chose qui est
quand même assez poignant et dur de me
semble être une des atroces n'oubliez
pas la signature quand même en passer
bah ouais cher mari je suis à bout de
souffle
cela fait plus de trois ans que juste à
la guerre est chaque jour ma révolte ma
lassitude se font un peu plus se sentir
je suis sur le point d'imploser seul ton
image me pousse à continuer et même
cette dernière commence à s'effacer
je n'en peux plus marie tu ne supporte
plus cette injustice si tu voyais tous
ces généraux manger à leur faim
vivre dans le confort pendant que nous
mourrons pour notre patrie ton mari
soldat victor paille à danville temps
payet vous l'avez inventé ou cette catin
soit là car ayant existé nom inventé il
ya de grandes chances pour qu'il ait
déjà et vous avez aussi né à traduire
dans une pièce à part je prends pas 2
oui oui
quatre lettres en pistolet dans le
premier tableau qui est en quelque sorte
le fil conducteur du premier tableau il
retranscrit les émotions du soldat
depuis son départ jusqu'à la fin de la
guerre vous rendez compte vous qu'il est
aujourd'hui bien dotées de la journée
sur un smartphone qu'à l'époque on
écrivait la halle est arrivé peut-être
moins d un mois et demi après avoir deux
mois rendez compte la différence qui a
horrible pour la femme ou pour
éventuellement d'hommes d'attendre des
nouvelles de son conjoint de sa
conjointe
aujourd'hui vous êtes tous sur messenger
snap chatter whatsapp et en quelques
secondes voire dizaines de secondes vous
avez des nouvelles de l'autre bout du
monde dans tous les cas je vous souhaite
de bien réussir demain soir bon parce
que le public qui sera là est acquis à
votre cause
il doit y avoir il à avoir au moins 90%
de parts en versant 10 % 10 % des
enseignants puis peut-être de nouveaux
talents pour la réunion merci les 18h30
et merci à vous
culture première c'est un jeune
réalisateur réunionnais de 33 ans que je
reçois ce soir dans ce studio de la
première son nom et yoann jean-charles
bonsoir bonsoir vous avez fait vos
études au collège juliette dodu le lycée
de vasseur bac en poche direction paris
pour des études de cinéma
diplômé en réalisation cinématographique
vous filez à new york pour deux ans
comme visionnaire pour les international
emmy awards en 30 et vous vous
perfectionner au pays de l'oncle tom
back to parisse vous écrivez votre
premier court métrage de fiction de 25
minutes disparition et puis vous voulez
écrire et réaliser votre premier métrage
à peu de frais et cela donne nuit de
grève et par jour de grève
ou l'histoire d'un coréen qui vient
retrouver une journaliste en france
votre film est sorti le 20 décembre 2017
c'est un signe pourquoi ne pas descendre
ah oui effectivement ça vous n'êtes pas
fait tilt dans votre tête
non j'étais à paris à ce moment là et
puis on devait préparer toute la sortie
du film donc à ce moment là on est
vraiment focalisé sur d'autres c'est pas
vous qui l'avez choisi la date
en tous les cas c'est celles exploitant
c'est moi même et l'exploitant parce
qu'il est sorti au cinéma
saint-andré-des-arts mais oui à ce
moment là on est tellement focalisés sur
la sortie que les choses autour j'ai bon
je pense que c'est inconscient vous avez
peut-être fait sans vous rendre compte
il y avait quelque chose qu'à
fonctionnaient bien alors j'ai regardé
le film puisque vous m'avez aimablement
permis d'avoir le lien de le regarder
puisque faut quand même en parler et je
ne suis pas allé presque jusqu'au bout
la famille est remis la main à la poche
apparemment oui tout à fait c'est il est
aimé faire une partie pour le film
effectivement les kasabian et
jean-charles et les années j'ai lancé
une campagne
ulule
donc il ya des donateurs voilà vienne
campagne de funding je sais pas quand je
sais pas combien a coûté cette pièce là
de pour ses jeunes fils a coûté de
l'argent ou pas certainement un tout
petit peu mais vous savez que les
réaliser son film avec 8000 euros c'est
ça je dis pas de bêtises et sûrement
moins de 8000 heureuse j'ai pas fait
alors comment comment on fait pour
réaliser un film avec moins de 8000
euros
ban toute l'équipe était bénévole d'une
part donc c'était on était tous des
dépôts tagro non non non c'était des
techniciens mais qu'ils étaient
intéressés par mon projet qui
souhaitaient me suivre pour labourer le
projet et et puis dès le départ jeu
lorsque j'ai écrit le scénario
j'écris un scénario qui soit réalisable
avec un tout petit budget j'ai choisi
des décors naturels peu de personnages
et et on a tourné en six jours aussi
donc on continue de du budget on pouvait
pas tourner plus de 6 jours et surtout
vous avez tourné la nuit et oui parce
qu'alors vous avez appelé louis de
gonzague justement pas en fonction des
contraintes que vous aviez ou parce que
vous aurez pu l'appeler jours de grève
alors je réponds pas pu l'appeler jours
de grève parce qu'effectivement ça ça
fait ça se passe la nuit
au départ j'avais peut-être envisager de
l'appeler jours de grève mais comme
l'histoire c'est parce que sur une nuit
voilà je me suis dit que c'est un peu
plus pertinent que ceux venus de grève
alors donc je disais tout à l'heure
c'est l'histoire d'un coréen qui arrive
à paris et qui d'un à la recherche d'une
journaliste qui l'a connue chez lui et
il en ferait de la chercher donc dans
paris mais surtout à noisy le grand
il est complètement paumé ce mec est
totalement paumées effectivement en fait
il s'est lancé dans cette aventure dans
ce périple
vraiment une part par impulsion sans
préparation et il se retrouve
pratiquement à la fin de du voyage et
les entre guillemets bloqué à la fin de
son voyage mais ils continuent et
continuent petit à petit voilà alors à
c'est un peu ma soeur anne ne vois-tu
rien venir enfin lui il essaye de voir
marin sera d'arriver enfin sa
journaliste active donc déclarer sa
flamme c'est bien ça si j'ai bien
compris et il se retrouve dans un
univers qui n'est pas le sien et donc il
est donc les nord-coréens il faut le
dire moi je connais pas la corée du nord
mais je suppose que ça ne ressemble pas
à paris certainement par là ne serait ce
que par l'architecturé et il est il et
il est en perte de repères oui
totalement perdu en fait je voulais
vraiment qu'ils soient plongées
effectivement dans un environnement
inconnu qu'il soit aussi déboussolé par
évidemment la langue qui ne parlent pas
et qu'ils soient aussi déboussolé par
rapport à la situation parce que la
situation se passe de nuit donc la nuit
un peu plus inquiétant que le jour il
traverse des boulevards des rues qui
sont voilà peu éclairé il rencontre des
personnes un peu malveillantes
certains certaines pas tout voilà
exactement il rencontre aussi des
personnes bienveillantes
c'est ce qu'il est justement à
poursuivre son périple
alors il a même pas téléphone diplômé il
n'y a même pas de gps la même page web
il a même pas google maps mais
franchement vous ne gagnez pas ce mec
ah oui il fallait qu'ils affrontent des
obstacles moi j'aime pas trop qui est
trop d'éléments
technologique enfin contemporain
informatique présent des téléphones des
andes il ya un ordinateur un moment qui
est présent mais je voulais larcat jeu
là mais je voulais vraiment qu'il soit
voilà pas aidé parce qu'effectivement
lorsqu'on a un téléphone portable et
qu'on a un forfait 4g et que voilà on
pianote sur son téléphone et on à
l'itinéraire sur google maps api réalise
votre truc là aujourd'hui en 2017 ou
2018 c'est totalement irréaliste
alors en plus difficultés de
communication il ne porte de la langue
il baragouine l'anglais il comprend plus
ou moins alors pour lui dès qu'ils
voient marie d'en marquer sur les trucs
de l'immeuble avant de chercher sur les
boîtes aux lettres
il s'adresse à tous de les marie est
évidemment échec il ne trouve pas la
personne est il fini ça finit en eau de
boudin votre truc là non plus non plus
effectivement l'objectif pour moi
c'était vraiment confrontés le
personnage a une aventure plus grande
que ce qu'il a l'habitude de vivre et de
d'aller au delà des obstacles
voilà qui rencontrent pas forcément
voilà peut-être retrouver marie mai en
tout cas aller au bout des obstacles
devront démarrer on n'en verra jamais de
toute façon facile à vivre la voix il
n'en va pas de revoir ça c'est certain
on ne sait pas effectivement mais c'est
dur dites moi il prête d'être d'une
grande timidité c'est vrai oui ça s'est
arrangé un petit peu au fil des années
vous veniez des jeunes avec un film qui
s'appelle comme ça je suis vidé je me
soigne alors quand on est un réalisateur
comme vous barre quand on a vous avez
décidé après c'est votre mère qui vous a
mis un peu le pied à l'étrier avec la
leçon de piano de jane campion c'est ça
alors ma mère de manière vraiment je
pars je pense pas volontaire c'est à
dire que effectivement lorsque j'étais
jeune allemand mais voir la leçon de
piano qui a un film et j'étais très
jeune je crois que j'avais 8 ans ou neuf
ans et qui marque énormément qui n'a pas
vraiment un film fait pour
un enfant de cet âge mais voilà moi que
j'ai adoré qui m'a beaucoup marqué et
qui m'a sûrement donner envie comme
d'autres fibres de continuer à voir des
films de continuer à m'intéresser au
cinéma l'audiovisuel et d'en faire
ensuite on a tort c'est ça le déclic
ou alors vous saviez depuis il avant
d'avoir vu ce film que vous en feriez
votre métier un jour non il n'y a pas eu
vraiment de déclic précis c'est vraiment
mon envie de 6,2 des films ma ma passion
pour le cinéma et ensuite j'ai découvert
comment les films étaient faits qui les
faisait et au départ je voulais être
acteur je voulais plus jouer dans des
films
j'ai découvert aussi que faire des films
ça pouvait être très intéressant et
voilà ça n'a plus est en 2d ce long
métrage j'ai fait beaucoup de choses
vous avez pratiquement tout supervisé
vous avez fait le montage vous avez fait
le casting est tout c'est ça alors de
toute façon le réalisateur c'est celui
qui supervise l'ensemble de son film
mais effectivement après comme il
s'agissait d'une d'une autoproduction
j'ai parti c'est moi qui ai fait
effectivement le casting de bout en bout
g
fignoler le montage pour moi qui ai fait
tout le montage mais je le finis au lait
j'ai fait beaucoup de repérage tout seul
mais j'étais encore même entouré d'une
équipe on était une petite quinzaine et
je savais qu'il fallait que je prépare
énormément la préproduction de mon film
pour pouvoir justement tourné pendant
ces six jours on n'avait pas le droit à
l'erreur j'avais pas de la scène dans le
rer
ça va être compliqué a tourné non
puisque vous tournez l'interviewer rer
il est perdu enfin on repart tout
raconter comment on fait dans ces cas là
parce que vous pouvez pas dire au
chauffeur du rer stop
aussi on s'est planté on recommence non
effectivement alors c'est pas si
compliqué que ça
en fait il ya une un train qui circule
entre la gare du nord et l'aéroport
charles de gaulle d'une traite et qui ne
marque pas d'arrêt entre les stations
qu'habituellement il marque et donc nous
on est entré dans dans ce train à gare
du nord on a fait on a demandé au
spectre voyageurs qui étaient présents
certains voyageurs s'il pouvait changer
de rame
et voilà on a monopolisé pendant 15
minutes puisque le trajet dure 15
minutes aller-retour pour pour faire les
plans les séquences tournées exactement
il avait trouvé où je vais passer des
castings j'ai passé des annonces voilà
il ya des gens qui m'ont répondu et puis
j'ai fait le tri j'ai ensuite on a fait
pas mal de répétition mais j'ai passé
des annonces à la base ils ont été payés
non personne n'a été payée elles vont
ils étaient d'accord tout le monde était
d'accord pour travailler gratuitement
sur le film parce que il était intéressé
par le projet est donc voilà comment
s'est fait le film vous avez de la
chance
est ce que ce serait passé de la même
manière à new york
oui oui en fait les des films peuvent se
faire vraiment juste part en vie par
passion et après il faut il faut
effectivement moi je suis très je
remercie énormément mon équipe parce que
sans eux je n'aurais pas pu faire le
film effectivement faire un film c'est
un travail collectif manière générale
et surtout en fait faire un film avec
une équipe qui est passionné qui qui
veut vraiment aller au bout du projet
qui compte pas ses efforts puissent
contourner 12 heures par jour ont tourné
la nuit ce qui est encore plus difficile
en menant vers dans le froid
effectivement voilà mais quand on a
entouré de gens comme ça qui sont
passionnés qui sont à toute aventure on
arrive à se dépasser on essaye d'aller
au bout de son projet a vraiment votre
héros au coréen il n'a pas très froid il
a juste un peu un ensemble jean et une
chemise
alors que les autres sont bien couverts
alors c'est parce qu'il a il est
vraiment corréziens qui n'a pas froid
oui sûrement parce que je pense que les
nord coréens ils sont physiquement
préparé un petit peu à la dureté afin de
la vie est déjà en corée au climat après
il faut savoir que l'acteur il n'est pas
correct nord-coréen alors il est
d'origine sud coréenne mais il est
français
oui parce qu'il annonce très
franchouillard tout à fait mais il a des
origines du sud coréenne il parle un
petit peu coréen voilà après lui l'était
faire habillée d'une veste en jeans d'un
petit pantalon mais en dessous pendant
le tournage on avait des candidats marc
voilà tellement bab des vêtements qui le
tenait chaud alors ils digue
on attend quand même pratiquement 20
minutes avant qu'il prononce un bois ce
coréen dans le film alors je porte du
corps et je parle pas des autres acteurs
je me suis en plus si c'est très très
lent vous fumez de façon très très lente
il à la façon dont
en fait ils découvrent le monde enfin il
découvre le monde parisien et il est
vraiment aux atlantes et aussi il est
aux aguets et
et je crois d exposition totale il est
vraiment promet ce mec
mais je pense qu'il a dû avoir une
mauvaise expérience de la france je suis
pas sûr parce que dans le film sans tout
raconter il rend compte quand même des
personnes bienveillantes mais une halle
et non plusieurs plusieurs quand même
plusieurs personnes et les deux là la
jeune fille la gamme
voilà là la concierge du gala de la
conseillère choix et la dame au standard
est également là la punk qui la compare
à celle qui l'accompagnent un peu
jusqu'au bout de sa recherche
après pour revenir à ma mise en scène
moi je voulais qu au départ le
personnage soit vraiment seul
je voulais pas qu'ils rencontrent tout
de suite des gens qu'ils soient qui est
toujours tout de suite dé des
interactions avec avec des personnes
effectivement après l'histoire se passe
en banlieue je voulais montrer la
banlieue parisienne qui est pas parfois
une banlieue enfin banale qui est qui
peut être banale mais qui a pour moi son
charme et qui qu'il faut montrer je
voulais pas tourner de nouveau à paris
parce qu'on connaît paris on connaît les
rues parisiennes
après on peut tourner à paris aussi dans
des rues désertes mais je voulais
vraiment aussi montré des décors qui
n'ont pas été montrés au cinéma
auparavant et les autres acteurs
sap a été cité vient dire facile ils ont
ils ont intégré rapidement le projet ou
pas oui oui vraiment je suis tombé sur
des gens à chaque fois qu'il était très
motivé par le projet qui était très
intéressé par le projet
après on a fait beaucoup de répétitions
pour que vraiment le jour du tournage
tous puissent rouler parce que comme je
disais on n'avait que six jours pour
tourner
mais le l'interaction entre chaque
acteur entre entre tim don qui est le
personnage principal du film et les
autres personnages s'est fait vraiment
très bien devenir nature ça veut dire
quoi budan jeu parisien j'ai entendu
boda boda
c'est quoi ces mots courir alors un mot
coréen effectivement c'est un mot pour
dire aussi corée la corée c'est parce
que je pensais
voilà donc et c'est même pas sous titré
alors là il ya des sous titres français
pour les parties parce que certains
dialogues qui sont en anglais mais
effectivement je voulais pas sous-titré
les parties en corée parce que il
prononce peu de choses et je veux
laisser le spectateur
voilà un petit peu dans l'inconnu par
rapport à ce qui dit on comprend on
déchiffre un petit entre guillemets on
se compare à celle d'hier alors jade et
ilan a osé pas de questions à poser aux
réalisateurs où il avait son âme à la
non ça va non même pas bah ouais ça même
pas bronché cinéma nous a dit vous êtes
branché cinéma oui qu'est ce que vous
regardez franchement de tous également
pas trop d'où romance tout ça mais le
reste on va dire j'ai vu le film de
yoann gens n'ont pas manqué ce que vous
attendez on va le voir elle était au
ritz jusqu'au 12 mai juin région d'agen
effectivement la rougeole est également
rex de saint pierre et de saint pierre
peut-être oui pour rendre à ensemble oui
on mettra deux ans aux professions avec
ses moufles oblige un réalisateur
réunionnais on n'a pas tous les jours
donc
voilà bien alors j'ai un peu embêté
parce que dans notre jardin on dit il
faut meubler parce qu'il ya une autre
personne qui est invité qui n'est
toujours pas là je sais pas quoi dire
quand même une pause il reviendra à vous
trois ah ok alors on écoute de la
musique
[Musique]
oh
il
ma théorie
etc
m
yama non
à qui
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
mais tous
[Musique]
m
18h51 vous êtes donc culture première
your hands jean charles est donc un des
invités de cette émission il réalisateur
son film lui de grève est sorti dans
l'année dernière est dit entre
actuellement projeté à la réunion au rex
et au ritz bonne chance vous avez
reconnu la musique non serait pas vous
dire ce titre j'ai pas très bon ça c'est
la musique de jeux vidéo jeux vidéo qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle adam jeu vidéo
de combat
king of fighters voilà c'est ça c'est
fatal fury n'atteint fatal fury ah non
si je les passais ce n'est pas innocent
pourquoi je les passais se sait et parce
que j'aime les jeux vidéo jeux vidéo de
combat particulièrement et dans dans un
des techniciens du film qui s'appelle
michael série qui a un très bon ami à
moi et chorégraphe de combat sur le film
et lorsqu on était jeunes ont joué à ce
jeu vidéo fatal fury et il ya un
personnage donc qui s'appelle kim et
voila voila et le personnage de 130
films et ça peut piquer mais également
qu'ils ont inventé devant kim kaphwan
voilà parce que moi je serai capable
prononcer je joue pas où je vais déroger
aux jeux vidéo les jeunes filles moi pas
trop mais je sais que jade oui j'en
avais alkis grave
non je me dis ah bon d'accord auquel on
pourrait peut-être faire les deux ferron
combat continue patton oui alors votre
film ça vous apportez new york que quand
comme expérience de sens quand même oui
deux ans elle a caché que vous habitiez
j'habitais à brooklyn the balkans non
non j'ai habité à brooklyn
après c'est très difficile en vain
lorsqu'on n'a pas beaucoup d'argent de
vivre à manhattan par exemple sont
exorbitants et je pense donc en général
on vit à brooklyn dans le queens est ou
dans le bronx
alors moi j'ai adoré mon expérience new
yorkaise je suis vraiment allé à la base
sans connaître new york j étais jamais
allé je fantasme et pas du tout new york
et j'ai découvert une ville vraiment
passionnante avec des gens qui viennent
des dunes monde entier un cosmopolitisme
qui est vraiment génial et puis j'ai
découvert aussi des gens qui sont très
ouverts qui tout le monde se parle dans
la rue dans le métro
et c'est une ville qui qui bouillonne
d'un mot d'un produit culturel
j'adorais la grosse pomme voilà la
grosse voix dont on ne connaissait la
grosse pomme du jeune fille non pas
parce que des parents attendent pour
vous emmener la question vous avez vu
comment il en ressort qu'il a fait en
plus il fait un film alors justement
notre film a été sélectionné
alors ils demandaient des festivals et
il vient d'être il était sélectionné il
ya trois semaines par le femi pour le
femi qu'un festival du film de la
caraïbe
là il commence en fait sont sa carrière
on va dire de deux festivals donc un
film on l'inscrit dans plusieurs
festivals et puis on attend que des prix
compense et les les britons voilà
exactement
alors comment il a été accueilli par le
public réunionnais bain plutôt bien
j'étais présent avec olivier car est
donc il est le réalisateur du mafate et
parce qu'il faut rappeler que nuit de
grève est programmée avec un autre film
qui s'appelle le mafatais qui était
tourné entièrement à la réunion qui est
un très très beau film de 53 minutes
et que donc il ya une double
programmation d'abord le mafatais
ensuite nuit de grève que ce soit aux
rites et au rex et nous nous avons fait
plusieurs après séance où on a rencontré
donc le public et les gens sont plutôt
positifs m le personnage je pense que le
personnage est très on a beaucoup
d'empathie pour le personnage local de
votre wii pour kim effectué en mai je
pense enfin moi j'adore le le mafatais
le on a put on ressent peut-être moins
d'empathie pour pour pour le mafatais
mais en tout cas on est sensible quand
même à son à son personnage peut-être un
bon travail là avec deux professeurs de
français pour voudrait voir ces deux
films l'a déjà dit non c'est vrai on
fait ce qu'il fallait les voir vous
allez voir mafate et moi j'ai été très
surpris aussi un parent par là la
facture du film est comme des nausées
une beauté des images à l'intérieur
seulement avocate réalisateur je vois si
vous avez aimé mémoire esthétiquement
j'ai aimé des images à la wii mais moi
j'ai tout aimé à la fois l'histoire que
j'ai trouvé très intéressante et les
plans aussi qu'ils sont très esthétiques
la la poésie qui se dégage du film qui
est pas une poésie mièvre qui est une
poésie un peu brut parce que l'histoire
et bruits les bouts de la ma cousine est
le personnage est brut mais voyez une
vraie poésie une vraie mythologie 1
kiki qui se révèle en fait du film de
l'histoire je trouve ça très très bien
aller prochain film séquences et où est
ben là je travaille sur plusieurs
projets j'ai un projet justement que
j'aimerais tourner à la réunion en petit
budget toujours
alors non la vraie budget ou là les
producteurs à mignon ça dépendra voilà
de ça on essaie d'avoir le plus d'argent
possible chaque fois donc à la réunion à
la réunion voilà
donc j'essaye de rencontrer des acteurs
de l'audiovisuel des producteurs pour
leur en parler alors parmi donc les
choses se posent les mécènes ayant un
certain félix antenor habazac qui a été
donc adjoint du sdiss à la réunion
pendant trois ou quatre ans donc il fait
partie des mécènes et je crois qu'il est
maintenant en guyane oui je crois que
c'est ça donc je sais pas si nous en
temps mais en tout le cas bonjour
affectionne anténor habazac donc mécène
donc du film de yoann jean charles qui
s'appelle donc le secteur le coréen qui
s'appelle nuit de grecs été tourné
entièrement à à paris et c'est le
premier réalisateur réunionnais a tourné
en france hexagonale merci en tous les
cas d'être venus tous les trois il ya
quelqu'un qui n'est pas venu je pas pour
quelles raisons bord succès pour demain
soir
son nom vous me verrez un sms pour me
dire si les gens ont aimé et puis
avouons succès aussi monsieur jan chan
mais pour la suite de votre carrière en
espérant qu'elle sera lors qu'un jour on
pourra vous voir monter les marches à
cannes
18h57 c'est la fin de cette émission
aura je vous rappelle que vous pouvez la
revoir cette émission en podcast sur le
site de la première au revoir est la
semaine prochain
[Musique]
un jour le roi odile à 10 mois la fine
il fait tout de pays gaulois pays
africains aux blancs pays européens and
bones haras el hodoud le chinois est
notre pause indien
un grand pot amérique